il ya une quinzaine d'années j'étais
directrice d'un service départemental de
l'état une direction départementale de
l'équipement pour ceux qui se
souviennent de ce que c'était ont géré
les routes les permis de construire et
tout un tas d'autres notre service un
peu moins de 1000 agents répartis sur
une dizaine de sites et l'état avait
décidé de transférer une majeure partie
des missions aux conseils généraux et
puis de réorganiser le reste c'était la
décentralisation
alors bien sûr les personnels ne
perdaient pas leur travail 1 mais il
était remis en question de façon assez
profonde certains allaient changer de
statut il allait devoir changer de lieu
il allait devoir changer d'employeur
changer de métier et donc ce jour là les
syndicats avaient organisé une
manifestation pour montrer leur
opposition
donc quand vous arrivez le matin vous
êtes le directeur et que vous savez que
vous attendent sur le parking plus d'une
centaine de personnes avec des
banderoles avec un mégaphone avec
beaucoup d'agressivité pour vous montrer
qu'ils sont totalement contre une
réforme que vous savez vous devrez
mettre en oeuvre vous avez le choix
vous pouvez aller vous garez
discrètement dans la rue on était en
centre ville
montez dans votre bureau dire à votre
drh que ben il faut qu'ils s'en occupent
parce que franchement c'est son boulot
le dialogue social
et puis vous avez des choses importantes
à faire il ya sûrement une réunion qui
va démarrer ou
vous pouvez faire le choix d'aller
d'aller discuter et ce matin là c'est ce
choix là que j'ai fait même c'était
difficile j'ai bipper la barrière s'est
ouverte je suis je suis rentrée sur le
sur le parking je me suis avancé dans la
foule
je suis garé et j'ai descendu de la
voiture et puis je me suis avancé vers
les leaders du mouvement
je les connaissais tous ces gens là on
avait l'habitude de travailler ensemble
mais la face à leur colère
c'était difficile c'était c'était pas
pareil mais je voulais leur dire
moi-même un que les décisions qu'on
allait prendre tiendrait compte de leurs
contraintes
je voulais leur dire que j'avais besoin
qui participent à les construire
et puis surtout je voulais qu'ils
ressentent que pour moi ça n'était pas
ils n'étaient pas des chiffres sur un
tableau de bord mais mais bien des
personnes comme moi avec leurs émotions
avec leurs contraintes personnelles avec
leur conscience professionnelle voilà et
donc malgré ma peur malgré leur
agressivité on a on a discuté on a tissé
doucement les fils de la confiance et
puis on arrêtait la manifestation ce
jour là et on s'est mis au travail on a
travaillé pendant deux ans et finalement
on a déployé la décentralisation au
mieux des intérêts de chacun je pense
alors pourquoi je vous raconte cette
histoire je voulais partager avec vous
trois histoires de ma vie
professionnelle pour pour démonter un
discours qu'on entend de plus en plus et
qui - m'insupporte monde change le monde
change de plus en plus vite et dans ce
monde qui change les entreprises
seraient devenus des lieux de souffrance
à cause de ces changements sur lequel
nous n'aurions eu prise est qui et qui
nous détruire et les responsables
seraient ailleurs finance les politiques
la mondialisation enfin chacun trouve
son bouc émissaire et nous attendrions
un homme providentiel pour nous sauver
c'est l'époque
finalement la seule solution la seule
alternative à la la dépression à la
démobilisation à la démotivation ce
serait serait la résistance ce serait la
révolte croire qu'on peut dire stop
moi depuis le début de ma carrière je
travaille dans des organisations au
changement mais comme vous je pense 1 et
depuis une vingtaine d'années j'ai
dirigé des organisations de taille
variable public privé de sens a presque
1000 personnes qui toutes étaient
confrontés à des évolutions très
importante ce qui m'a ce qui m'a guidé
dans ses évolutions sur ses fonctions
c'est c'est la conscience que les
entreprises sont d'abord des gens sondés
communauté d'individus comme vous comme
moi et finalement ce sont pas des
décideurs lointain qui font notre notre
quotidien professionnel mais bien les
gens que nous côtoyons directement par
par leur comportement et par là la
qualité notre interaction les uns aux
autres et donc c'est bien chacun qui
choisit chaque jour soit de poursuivre
son projet personnel en compétition avec
les autres voire en considérant que ce
sont des obstacles à leur propre sa
propre réussite à sa propre à son propre
épanouissement professionnel
professionnelle ou au contraire de
poursuivre un projet plus collectif
[Musique]
construire un mois ce que j'appelle un
écosystème de développement
d'apprentissage dans lequel finalement
chacun va trouver grosso modo sa place
et qui sait au fur et à mesure poser les
problèmes qu'ils concernent y apporter
des solutions les plus adaptées possible
construire finalement un environnement
plus plus conforme à nos souhaits en
vous racontant l'histoire de la dde
d'eure-et-loir
je voulais vous faire partager le fait
que même même dans des environnements
très contraint dans des environnements
conflictuelle on pourrait penser qu'on a
on n'a pas d'autre solution que de ce
fait face et derrière des règles des
décisions prises par d'autres là une loi
des process des procédures quand on
pourrait penser qu'on n'a pas de marge
de manoeuvre en fait ton gars toujours
le choix et c'est cette liberté là que
nous avons pris ce jour-là les syndicats
et moi même on a pris le risque
d'assumer nos marges de manoeuvre pris
le risque de la prise de responsabilité
du du dialogue puis de la coopération et
donc on a réussi à construire une forme
d'intelligence collective et c'est grâce
à cette intelligence collective qu'on a
trouvé qu'on a construit ce des
solutions qui était satisfaisante à un
problème que nous n'étions pas préparés
à résoudre ni les uns ni les autres
cette intelligence collective
comment on la construit de mon point de
vue il ya deux ingrédients fondamentaux
pour avancer dans ce sens le premier
type d'ingrédients c'est c'est la
bienveillance et l'empathie c'est je
dirais même c'est la gentillesse
alors quand on part gentillesse on
entend généralement on n'est pas chez
les bisounours 1 mais moi je dis
pourquoi pas c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est google
je sais pas si vous avez lu les
résultats de cette étude
qu'ils ont mené plus presque 200 équipes
audit et il cherchait à savoir
finalement qu'est ce qui rendait les
équipes les plus performantes
donc ils ont testé plein de critères et
est le critère principal auquel sont
arrivés c'est la gentillesse le sait le
niveau de gentillesse entre les mains en
bas et finalement c'est assez naturel
puisque quand on a confiance les uns
dans les autres
quand on sait qu'on peut compter sur les
gens qui sont autour de soi on prend des
risques on est innovant on est créatif
on avance et le deuxième le deuxième
ingrédient pour construire cette
intelligence collective
c'est l'engagement individuel c'est la
vision du colibri que raconte pierre
rabhi la légende elle dit que un jour
dans la forêt il ya eu un immense
incendie est alors l'ensemble des
animaux assisté impuissant au désastre
il était atterré terrifié et il ya juste
un petit colibri qui s'agite il prend de
l'eau avec son bec et puis il va ajouter
quelques gouttes d'eau sur le feu il
retourne chercher de l'eau il jette
quelques gouttes d'eau comme ça ces
allers retours ça ça agace le tattoo qui
finalement lui dit mais arrête colibri
tu vas pas l'éteindre le feu
colibri s'arrête le regarde et lui dit
je sais je ne suis pas fou mais je fais
ma part
un deuxième exemple personnel j'étais
jeune ingénieur c'était mon
mon premier poste j'étais responsable
d'un bureau d'études d'ingénierie dans
le domaine de l'eau de l'assainissement
la gestion des rivières et alors là où
je travaillais la norme en termes de
gestion des rivières à l'époque c'était
de canaliser les rivières donc c'était
un peu une catastrophe en termes d'éco
système est donc en tant que jeune
ingénieur j'essayais de faire évoluer
les choses pour qu'on utilise des
techniques plus plus naturel vous avez
confié un gros projet nasa concerné à un
effondrement des berges de seine
d'ailleurs pas très loin d'ici
et donc je devais présenter mes
préconisations techniques on était dans
une dans une grande salle en bord de
seine j'étais la seule femme
j'étais tout jeune ingénieur il y avait
que des messieurs d'un certain âge
en face de moi c'est les experts du
ministère et donc j'ai présenté mon
projet 100% naturel avec que des plantes
voilà il ya eu il ya eu un grand blanc à
la fin de ma présentation et je me suis
fait clairement de renvoyer dans mes
buts comme si j'étais totalement
incompétente
une vraie blonde et j'ai bien compris
dans leurs regards qui se disait mais
voilà comment est ce qu'on a pu recruter
sur ce poste
une jeune femme comme ça ces histoires
de petits poissons de plantes c'est bien
une histoire de femme c'est pas une
histoire d'ingénieurs bon vous avez
compris que c'est pas ce jour là que
j'ai réussi à convaincre mais surtout
renée un certain nombre de fois en
gardant le sourire et puis surtout on a
travaillé ensemble avec des collègues on
a créé un réseau de site pilote pour
montrer que ça pouvait marcher on a
mobilisé des expériences étrangères et
finalement on a réussi à convaincre et
en on assez peu de temps on a changé la
norme et vous voyez moi c'était juste et
le colibri c'était
mon 1 117 et ses rivières que l'on
détruise est à force de béton et avec
mes petites gouttes d'eau j'ai participé
à l'éteindre et c'était une grande
fierté
alors vous aussi je suis sûr que vous
avez un incendie qui vous préoccupe
il ya sûrement des choses que vous avez
envie de devoir changer
mettez-vous en mouvement proposer des
solutions
en plus le temps joue pour vous par
exemple les études disent que d'ici cinq
ans 50% des métiers qui recruteront
n'existe pas encore
ça veut dire que les marges de manoeuvre
sont sont énormes
et puis surtout n'ayez pas peur de
l'échec
ce conte on n'y arrive jamais du premier
coup 1 il faut revenir revenir les
enfants tombent au cou avant de savoir
marcher alors ce qui est difficile en
france
dans cette dynamique là c'est qu'on est
nourri à la défiance
donc c'est pas facile de d'embrayer dans
ce sens le quand on regarde les études
internationales à la france est toujours
en queue de peloton sur cette thématique
là moins d'un français sur quatre
considère qu' on peut globalement faire
confiance aux autres c'est c'est presque
40 % pour la moyenne des pays de l'osce
et des oeufs et je vous parle pas de
certains pays d'europe du nord on est à
50 60 %
ça ça veut dire que on élève nos enfants
dans cette idée là et donc ça veut dire
qu'on les monts les plombent pour agir
dans ce monde qui est le nôtre désormais
où le niveau le niveau d'incertitude le
niveau de complexité va nécessiter de la
coopération pour agir donc de la
confiance et donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
eu envie d'aller prendre le mal à la
racine
[Musique]
j'ai voulu avancer sur cette question là
en tant que directrice d'école
d'ingénieur ce sera mon dernier exemple
j'ai fait le pari que l'école pour les
étudiants ça pouvait être la première
entreprise à laquelle ils coopèrent et
que dans cette entreprise là on allait
leur faire pratiquer concrètement
l'intelligence collective de façon que
ensuite ils puissent essaimé et qui
puisse apporter cette façon de
travailler dans les différentes
entreprises qu'il rejoindrait plus tard
et donc c'est pour ça que quand on que
les nouveaux locaux qu'on a inauguré
l'année dernière à l'estaca étaient les
plus ouverts et les plus décloisonner
possible pour que finalement les
étudiants les enseignants les chercheurs
les personnels administratifs lé les
partenaires et le plus possible
d'occasions de ceux de se croiser de se
parler de se connaître et donc de
coopérer d'avancer ensemble de faire des
choses ensemble
c'est pour ça aussi que quand on a
travaillé sur le campus numérique on a
décidé que les étudiants aussi pourrait
produire des contenus pédagogiques pour
que finalement ils apprennent à se
soutenir et à s'entraider les uns les
autres au delà de leur simple cercle
d'amis c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a fait
évoluer sur plusieurs années le système
de distribution ddd moyens qui étaient
alloués aux projets associatifs aux
projets des étudiants passer d'un
système où c'est l'administration qui
distribue ses moyens un système où ce
sont les étudiants qui font les choix et
on a mis plusieurs années parce que la
confiance là le sens des responsabilités
la prise de responsabilités ça se
décrète pas ça se construit et
finalement il a fallu déconstruire un
certain nombre de représentations et de
comportement particulier ceux qui
étaient liés à la à la peur de
l'arbitraire la peur du copinage en lien
avec le pouvoir
et puis en construire d'autres plus
propice à la confiance
voilà j'espère que au travers de ces
exemples j'aurais su j'aurais réussi à
vous faire partagé ma conviction qu'on
est tous coresponsables du futur qui se
construit à vous vous donnez envie de
d'assumer de mobiliser vos marges de
manoeuvre envie de vous engager pour
participer à construire le monde que
vous souhaitez envie de coopérer envie
d'aller vers vers vos collègues de
travail
alors ce que vous appréciez bien sûr
mais aussi ceux qui vous agace parce que
comme vous ils sont fragiles ils sont
peut-être en attente avec avec leurs
peurs avec leurs difficultés à
communiquer mais mais aussi avec avec
leurs envies avec leurs rêves avec leur
passion faites leur confiance
faites vous confiance merci
[Applaudissements]